contact right smugly we should hit that
wall and then whoa bill down pull
straight that buy you ten very small he
comes it and then we rotate
you
all around
mid-foot wait my torso has already that
count for the rear posterior chain then
I bring him in and then it's a spiral
going up that sends him back the other
way now we have contact then I follow
that
[Music]
the connection point is here both that's
really happened hi my face do you see
you
Oh your ski Punisher hmm good yeah good
so right go ahead and take that with
this
[Music]
and transfer what you're feeling on one
side to the other side so here an IV
butter it's not it's not hard is it no
but you're aiming you're aiming it ended
him okay
even if he lets go you still have it
there's really nothing in that hat your
mind is you're in
[Music]
it's gonna drive that arm here then this
hand captures it and I feed it he's
gonna think the figure-four so he's
defending that way go back so he thinks
figure forward and I come up to the bar
he defends the figure floor defense the
check you're gonna have the wrist
pulling the head do you see that and
that can go right into another carotid
and he's going to defend that right well
thank you
when he goes right into the arms his arm
right you'll just take the armbar
[Music]
deviating deviations deviating deviate
you
Yeah right let me grab you this is the
sign intention that the organization
right there I have I'm not like this so
I'm here right
lean on me alright I'm working with that
and she pushes same organization so I'm
not using my feet to breaks okay
[Music]
you
he's taking me into it no in blend
[Music]
you
I lost there's a lot of weight on our so
I'm not going to fight the heart so it
comes up I let it go on everything
now you try to counter this okay
yes I'll continue the center's
everything is fine
[Music]
I slide up the arm as I move and this
torque goes here you see that not like
that see how you're not going to pull
the chicken wing on up this way to the
more angles you combined in an
articulation the more torque you create
at the joint so this is one plane you
see that right well and this is another
plane right now I'm going to combine the
two you see whoop right use the in space
to let them to go in and you drop the
elbow right on the chest but you're
still in Turing through the center you
see that so I'm not going backwards
we're gonna she's a fall on me so I'm
projecting forward then I drop with her
this is this space you see I mean it
should already be tight if you need to
finish it you're coming in right and she
you feel healthy not that he got really
strong there and she pushes really far
in here right said she's countering you
so you don't want to go like this now
you just work with that energy oh that's
good enough right look I can go around
it because it's here don't let me get
you see it's in the front so I'm gonna
go around this way
feel it you'll go here I feel it boom
come around it there it is again for
every time it's rounded it's telling you
what to do again boom
you
okay so boom of the charge you see it's
in your palm right and then I'm gonna
disappear that and I can feel that's
upon me right so I'm going to not keep
working on that I'll go around it and
then I feel that right there right you
feel that and I'm not gonna pressure
there because you be strong be strong
you see so I gotta go around it again
see I'm taking it off like that okay and
then I climb over to this hop and if I
cut down here be strong you think you're
weak be strong okay now watch I'm gonna
lift my elbow and I went up I went
around it you see so the way that you
want to think of this technique is it
looks like two swords or engaging but
one of them's going around the other one
he should never feel it
someone is reconciling my my energy
you're like oh it's on you see that you
have to take you chemi you have to go
where it's taking you to go what the
beginner tends to do is when they fall
into the alley park right then they fall
however they want and if he keeps going
I'm falling away from the law do you see
that and it's gonna hurt and usually
because we're all so nice here if we let
you up and out of it but you're not
improving okay
so in the same way that he goes around
your energy now it's my turn
you see and I reconciled that energy and
then I'm practicing the inside he's
practicing the young side sookay I'm
just reconciling that energy every time
over and over and over that's all I'm
doing
okay so I'm coming in Oh reconciling you
don't have one you can't meet because
you don't know why he's gonna do you
don't know what you're gonna do but you
always reconcile eleven energy so he you
should cut it in the air not cut it to
me hahaha hey it doesn't change how fast
I go he should always cut it in the air
[Music]
sometimes it's enough in your you can
leave your hand there right and I'm just
going to relax it and it said not to
start and move me so here we are they
lean on me okay and then I'll just relax
my arm and you see it starts
[Music]
you have to keep tension in the elbow
understand yes so there's this not this
okay and I don't know what it's going to
be because as you move I have to move
you see how do you understand that so
it's more of a feeling a feeling some
people will want to fall on you once
they figure out put our hash go ahead
right and then the arm has an intention
again but it was for your training you
don't ever let that happen
no you always detention okay there you
go like this no tension tension you see
like that it works as a leverage not
just here the whole thing is worth right
get out
[Music]
each time faster keep going
oh we're you're not a big slug between
reps now is that how it is you don't
discipline yourself it's all gonna be
external always you can always need me
get that knee in there right in his face
or not
do you look like you don't know any
strike is that true that's weird
[Music]
I'm late so I have to hurt okay so try
to have it whether you're out here
you're timing the openings you started
earlier so you'd have to race there okay
I don't see all the way down I don't see
it remember not to follow him down on
your projections that's why we have
stomps I'll know what that is
you
[Music]
same thing getting up just fits just
fits same thing right here's where you
want the neutral
you
[Music]
there's a lot of acceptance right when
you say so
[Music]
what I try to to note is that when I
would do you see how I am affecting her
base look this looks different for your
role and unlike that you see that I
think I'm always looking for that kind
of like if I can push lift their face
because that even when I come over here
right there's a time right over here
can't just be like this arm here right
just get up
that's the lift that you have in your
coke you nargiz and you're not just
turning so even when your hand comes way
out here right don't use it to get their
balance and topsy-turvy
push push it into them okay so you get
more of that feeling and what's that
Center feel like okay
you
[Music]
you can see that I can keep going so I
just do this I'm doing that into the
technique so I'm here see how I can
transition to forward right away
don't start walking backwards
[Music]
so it's not he's gonna stab me but
you'll pay attention more if that's in
that other that's in that you have to
take a me
[Music]
the drill we don't I don't want you to
go like wait inside outside is that's
taken away from reptile but generally
one hand is on the outside the one hand
is on the inside but if I come and we me
like that I'm not gonna go you're just
taking away repertoire so just make
contact Luke it is going to push up my
chest and push with this hand they can
push with the other hand you see and I
go and then I'll find the connection and
I'll push out
along the way from when your to skill
development it's just about the rest
okay
Loretta reps and then some pointers reps
and rep so some of the things so as he's
going here right to see his linear
energy what we're doing is not this see
I'm not moving out of the way so I've
seen a lot about your going like this
and then you're pulling on us so here's
how you can show that that I'm not doing
that as he's pushing you see he's not
going past me when I move out when I
move out of the way so we're moving at
my place that at any point this can't
just stop you see that there's a
structural integrity to it okay so I'm
gonna you're gonna keep doing your push
and you can see I'm slowing him down
I'm turning him you see
okay I'm attorney
[Music]
so you all like this you know here like
this that's totally different right okay
so I'm here connected wool so you if you
if you're getting it really easy baby
unit if you're not right do it at a
slower pace
[Music]
so you could do that you can do this
okay wherever it doesn't matter say you
start where okay that's really goes and
then we have to do this same drill so he
aggresses right
[Music]
you
by my my mind is you can do whatever
right so here's looking looking so
you're on one leg and now hit me hit me
hard you see no I'm not dressed right
do you understand that not at the cost
of whatever
you
so I'm here I'm constantly looking for
openings I'm blending in and y'all
so the board that that we can struggles
at the door I see what I was trying to
do I stay the same
he gets more tired technique it's more
violent but I don't I don't
okay so he's trying to get up
[Music]
you
oh he's coming at you up keep lights out
because like see how I'd stay here and
not like this
alright then here let him go Oh for you
but get up my feet are under me you see
all right so you can okay home here he
comes
Oh
he's pushed his pushing on me
right okay now I'm just grounding you're
pulling actually push push push though
and then I'm in the ground and then I'm
doing so that that is exactly what so
I'm not good at this I just hit the
ground
[Music]
and now you're now you're a unit and
then I can drop this I'm engaging him
[Music]
so his energy is pushing right and will
let it go around pass it up to my armpit
so same thing is I'm here push you see
I'm not getting compromised sure so I
need that face to send his energy around
in my armpit same thing he pushes go
right by the same thing I just keep
redirecting it into the ground so I'll
go ahead warm around cool in
[Music]
oh I thought you're going to change size
of it you can feel it go he doesn't
bother you'll feel it
[Music]
I'm free to move
okay the horn right boom strike draw now
boom pop drop dance the drill
boom ah then we're dealing with nine pop
straw boom so I can hit home strike
climb up by Ken reject
try to have this whatever you're doing
so project oh it goes right into your
presentation
boom don't get stuck you see that
difference through this seamless